what's up everybody thank you for
joining us at little light today we got
a very unique story but how does little
light studios
save someone's marriage find out on this
episode of
led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness what's going on
everybody we have two very special
guests today we have
daniel and michaela with us i met them
because
when we get comments on youtube we read
those comments and so
michaela she had her own little channel
going on and she i remember the first
thing i ever saw was
that she said please pray for my
boyfriend he's an atheist wow
yeah and so like she was saying you know
i'm starting to watch your videos
and like my you know they're starting to
reveal some things to me my eyes are
being open
and then i started seeing you know we
kind of had this dialogue back and forth
where
you know i would comment back like oh
you know that's cool and then
you know comments kind of get lost on
youtube and stuff so i was like why
don't we
start doing email and stuff but i want
to hear like some backstory
like what was the deal you were an
atheist how did that happen like were
you
not raised in a christian home at all
basically i was raised in a catholic
house
if anything um they were
quote unquote catholics but they weren't
really practicing it too much
always kind of skipping out on mass and
whatnot and
then i kind of just started questioning
the faith i had all these questions
about it
they didn't have answers to it so i
continued to question question it and
school kept pushing out this
evolution and all this stuff and this is
how it really is
and oh this is all fairy tale you can't
be listening to religion anymore
right and so i fell for that trap
essentially
and i became one of those i would say
evangelical
atheists going out yeah going out there
pushing people you know going out there
pushing my atheism on other people it
was like on facebook pages
for like atheism yeah it was bad it was
real bad
where would you say your influence came
from was education or
the school that you went to the main
influence and you leading
down the road to becoming an atheist and
you as well like was school the main
thing that
led you down a road of christianity i'd
definitely say it was
school if anything they're always
pushing out evolution was the way we're
all been created
and that just completely goes against
what the bible teaches and
it really gets you starting to think oh
well is the bible true
they said this is true dinosaurs are
this old right oh
i gotta i gotta get the right answers
and then you
continue on that route it just pushes
you further and further away from god
but you never get the right answers
anyways
they're scientists it's in the textbook
it's gotta be true
and for me i actually we wouldn't even
get in arguments about it too because i
never actually believed
all that stuff i didn't know how to
explain it because i
wasn't scientifically inclined to i'm
just not good at that type of stuff
but i'm like it's just not real like
that's just as far as i would get with
it
but i actually grew up in a christian
background where my grandfather is a
pastor okay so i grew up in the church
and i started going and then around like
12 13 years old i think like mostly just
the people that i was influenced by
and you know of course mainstream media
like the tv i was watching
and all that it made me like kind of
push out a way to do what made me feel
good
yeah so that's kind of like what
happened for me yeah because
growing up i was taught like there's
three prongs to the to stabilize a stool
so one is the home the other is the
church and the last one is
school so if you're getting neglected
spiritually neglected at home
and either you're not going to church or
you're not getting much from church
and then school is meant to educate you
so depending on what you're learning in
school that can really
direct you in where you go whether it's
atheism or people who go to church
school and they become true believers or
wherever you decide to go so it's really
important
at least to have one but of course all
three and pointing in
media is definitely programming they
call it programming for a reason but
uh they they normalize things you know
over time we've seen
where i love lucy you know they wouldn't
even sleep in the same bed and they're
wearing pajamas buttoned up to their
neck to now it's like
reality tv where the whole house of
people are getting drunk and
you know hooking up and all this stuff
so that becomes normal to our
our generation we look at that and
that's normal and then you look
to the church and they don't look much
different either so for you to say
you know you believed in god but your
life was really kind of just
not not and you're not living according
to biblical standards
that's just like normal lukewarm
christianity today
yeah so how did you meet michaela have
verizon actually yeah i was right
i was working as a sales rep and then
okay i ended up getting
him to switch over from t-mobile
she's persuasive
[Laughter]
i dropped the thousand dollars right
there on a new phone
right there yeah that's basically how we
met
then after that we kind of just started
hanging out and we got to know
each other a little bit more started
dating
and then we went through a couple rough
patches actually ended up breaking up at
one point
came back together because she started
showing me all these things from led
and it opened my eyes to what the world
is really being influenced by
maine media pushing out all these kind
of uh
demonic type of influences out on all of
us basically
and i realized that what type of
influence i was under
especially since i was addicted to video
games that's all i'd ever do really i
just
go to work come home play vegans oh i
get that
you would be like obsessed with video
games and like spend hours on that
instead of like
hanging out with me oh super anti-social
because of it too
it was uh it got really bad and then
i i started praying as soon as she
started sending me your guys videos
well hold on back back up a little bit
because you guys there was a rough patch
but
what caused that rough pattern i know a
little bit of the back story it was
it was kind of your beliefs right
because you were coming to the faith at
this point
yeah so like i mean i wasn't like of
course like i wasn't
i wouldn't say i was like born again but
i knew that there was a god
and so i was you know reading my bible
and doing that but then at the same time
i was drinking and i was partying and i
was doing all these things but i knew
that there was god and i wasn't
i wouldn't say i was born again but we
even had arguments times about like
evolution and certain things and
everything happens for a reason and he
used to believe like it didn't and it
was just like all coincidence
so we had little bicker like arguments
about it
before and then i don't know i guess in
i guess before he broke up i started
really becoming a christian and like
reading the bible and then when we broke
up my mom suggested reading psalms
you know i should to mend a broken heart
and so i started reading songs and
that's kind of when
i started like whoa like this is real
like this is i need to change my life
and that's kind of when that started
god's word yeah so you were raised in a
christian home and you were living like
the world but
something brought you to a point where
you wanted to start
studying the bible and and that started
convicting you
what got you to that point i think it
was just like different hardships that i
like went through in my life
and it's just kind of like is this it is
this literally what life is all about
and
i always knew that god was real like i
always knew that he was there but it's
like i wasn't living for him
he doesn't judge me yeah i was like like
a progressive christian
[Laughter]
yeah i know i was very lukewarm and it's
like i mean i would say something about
like god loves me and then the same time
i'm like partying and i'm drinking and
i'm hanging out with people who
clearly don't love god um and then
we actually broke up at one point
because of the
unequally it was definitely yeah it was
definitely had something to do with that
um we were having well i mean part of
his testimony too is that he was dealing
with depression
and he was like super addicted to video
games and i mean i was doing my own
thing too living for myself
and living for the world and i think it
just
became just heavy on us and so we broke
up
and there's a lot of stuff going on like
with our friends and family and
because of like my beliefs and so
and it's like his family didn't like
your beliefs yeah
yeah oh yeah and a lot of his friends
too but same with my friends and it was
just
very um like heavy i don't know how to
explain it other than that but it just
got to
us and um now that we're like married we
can see that like
that was definitely like the devil
trying to split us up but he knew
something good was gonna happen
and he wanted to you know i wouldn't
ever give him the power of like what god
has
but it's like he knew something good was
gonna happen and that you know he was
getting closer and closer because
we were even like watching videos and he
was like you know what it all started
really small with him being like
maybe things do happen for a reason
too i'm praying today to next thing you
know
he's over there if we got to a point
where we watch all your guys videos and
we're like what else is there well how
did you get to the videos because okay
you said you were like uh
what did you say when i said oh he
doesn't judge me or whatever like a
progressive christian order so
a christian that believes like oh we can
have abortions and homosexuals okay yeah
but your grandma said something right oh
yeah so i was pro-choice at the time too
and you know and it was funny because
i've been like questioning it for a long
time and i remember even talking to my
mom about it
and being like mom like what do you
think about abortion and she was like i
think it's just like a woman's
choice and it's not for me to decide i
want to get one personally yeah
but why why wouldn't you right and so
then i went to my grandma's house one
day and she was like kayla come here
and she was like you whatever you do in
your life
never get an abortion it will destroy
you and i'm like there's a lot of pain a
lot of
heaviness in the way she approached that
so
um you know she's 70 something years old
i'm gonna listen to her so i started
looking up abortion
and i watched that movie unplanned and
it was like three o'clock
in the morning when i'm watching this
movie and i stayed up
just researching all this stuff about
abortion and that's when i found you
guys for that was the first video i ever
watched of you guys
so i was like going on this youtube
rabbit hole of abortion
issues and then i found so we are in the
algorithm right
all right yeah so that's the first video
i ever saw
and then i was like i love the way that
you guys interact and your perspectives
and all that and i was like i gotta
watch more so then it started
to be coming in my recommended all the
time so i and then we were broken up at
the time
so then i was sending him videos and i
felt like i'm just alone watching all
these youtubers no i was literally like
in my bed
just so that's all i would do and i was
like pray for my boyfriend
because like we broke up but i knew it
wasn't like official
like in my head she's gonna get you back
i was like i mean it seemed like the
only way he would reply to me
is if i sent him a little lights video
you guys were super interested
this is some heavy stuff that's what
we're hoping for
yeah reach people who wouldn't step foot
in the church you know we're trying to
that's right
look at look at the evidence you know
just why are they doing this you know
yeah yeah so i was just sending him
videos and the first video i ever sent
it was a peter pan
and i mean like that is just really
heavy information
and that that subject matter we were
like already researching stuff like that
and so it just seemed like oh this will
hit close to home to him
so i sent him that video and i think the
next video i sent him was l house
which was so obvious right so i sent him
that video
what did you think about that when you
saw it
i i just thought it couldn't get any
more in your face right yeah like
the lady admits that yeah i got this uh
idea from hell itself wow
okay i mean i showed it to my mom
she didn't see anything she didn't see
anything wrong with that wow it
surprised me i was like wow
yeah that's scary it's scary to think
that there's a lot of people just like
that
that's completely oblivious all this
sort of question
so you were atheist but did you believe
in god
no so you completely did not i i didn't
believe in him whatsoever
i thought everything happened by
accident a big explosion created the
most complicated
life forms in existence uh it's
it was a ridiculous fairy tale to
believe for sure and how about
you know atheists they don't believe in
god but do they believe in satan
believe it or not yes yeah they they all
talk about satan on atheist forms for
some reason it's the weirdest thing ever
they're saying oh well the funny story
is that in the bible satan's actually
the good guy when you read it i'm like
how how and it's it's ironic that
you know we're atheists wouldn't believe
any of this stuff but
40 of our posts are debunking god it's
like
wait a minute why would you waste so
many hours of your life debunking
something that's
you don't believe in like me spending
all my life like
the easter bunny's not real i can prove
it guys
why i wouldn't do it because why are you
so upset about it if it's just a fairy
tale right let me just be crazy
but so my my idea is that there's no
real true atheist
there there's people who want to do what
they want to do they don't want to face
the judgment or whatever so they're
going to try to find any way they can to
not believe in god
which usually means not reading the
bible and just looking
like you posted a meme it was hilarious
it was a perfect thing like
a scientist opens up this little thing
it says i've read the bible cover to
cover and it made me an atheist
and he puts it under a microscope and
it's like a hundred percent and it's
like
uh what did they say i googled like
bible verses that were
bad or whatever yeah in reality i
actually just googled the immoral bible
verses or whatever
it's like i think that's the way it
really is well actually you remember
when we would have like conversations
you'd like i read the bible like no you
didn't and now he admits to like i never
i believe that's the case a lot of times
you know they don't want to be held
accountable for their
uh life and they'd rather believe that
everything was just a big accident
i was there one time i was like somebody
asked me how
where did all this stuff come from i was
like i can believe that this world just
always existed
more than i can just believe some guy in
the sky i can't see or have any kind of
senses
always existed this world has been here
for as long as anybody knows about so
to me it's a lot easier to believe that
this always existed but
it's just a way to get out of believing
in god
yeah so do you have any advice on like
how to even approach answering something
like that when you're talking to someone
who's heavily scientific or even you
daniel because you're coming out of that
right what answer do you think would
have like helped you um
i'd say definitely do some more research
go out there see what the other
perspective is just
don't listen to what the tv is saying
tv's always going to push out the same
narrative yeah all the time they're
never going to change their narrative
they might change it to suit their
narrative to
whatever they want to do whatever they
want to push out but they're never
going to really push out christ if you
if you want the truth if you want the
answers you have to look for them
yourself basically yeah
i i all i did is i went on genesis
apologetics
you got tons of information they can
explain
everything and it just shows evolution
is practically impossible
yeah that's what's awesome about our
generation like when when i was a kid
there
wasn't a lot of resources the vhs tapes
that are overpriced and stuff like that
and how do you get ahold of me
and we have no excuse and i i think
people should not be afraid to
research on either side if you're you
know
as a christian i will watch whatever
video you want me to see
and i'm i'm strong enough in
what i believe to be true that i can
often show well that
scripture doesn't show that you know and
as a
as an atheist or someone like that you
shouldn't be afraid to look
what is what are these creationists
saying right could it possibly be true
that
these layers in the strata don't
represent millions of years but
actually like layers and layers of
mudslides that happen
as a flood was coming and they were
formed rapidly as opposed to
looking at the bottom layer being like
oh we must have all been insects because
everything down here is smaller
or maybe all the smaller creatures got
covered first and then the
bigger creatures got covered next and
then you know you step back at these
strata layers and it's
just like life you got little things
down here and bigger things on top
and it happened rapidly but they'll say
no that was millions of years ago
so you know you should have a non-biased
approach when you're you're studying for
truth and seeking for truth
and yeah uh answers to genesis is a good
one kent hovind is a really good one
at debunking evolution and there's just
so many
more out there today so that's awesome
was that like a huge influence on did
what actually got you to the point where
you started looking at that stuff
because
definitely you guys i would say yeah i
was starting to get a little bit more
information on what the media is
actually doing
through you guys you guys who are
showing what they're pushing out there
all the stuff that they're using to kind
of manipulate our children
and it started to kind of worry me and i
was like oh wow this
is this is blatantly right in front of
your face
it's like propaganda yeah they're not
hiding this whatsoever they're pushing
it
right out there putting right in front
of the television saying to your kids
hey it's okay watch as much television
as you want it's like
uh yeah that seems a little fishy and
then
man it was uh it was a pretty rude
awakening realizing what i
been exposing myself to basically what
would you say was your quality of life
like were you
a happy person as an atheist no not at
all no
not at all i was uh constantly
constantly just abusing substances
really i was kind of sad i thought i was
a pretty happy atheist i was like oh
i'm doing pretty good you know i got a
decent job and
i'm working every single day
yeah no it was uh it was pretty sad
there was just a lot of
kind of like anger for some reason i
felt like i was
but i said no there's no god but i felt
like i was angry at god
so it was uh it was kind of ridiculous i
felt
you still feel conviction yeah still
feel conviction no matter what you do
you say there is no god well guess what
god's still gonna put that conviction in
your heart
he's gonna let you know when you're
doing something wrong so it's uh
no getting away from that yeah i feel
like atheists are like there's no god
and then when they have cancer god why'd
you do this to me wait a minute the god
that you rejected
and you know mocked all his people
i just don't see that logic uh another
question is like when you watch
owl house did we we didn't even mention
about like there is
god did we we didn't even explain about
that right so what
uh what the video did the video answer
something that you have
questioned uh well i was definitely
wondering how twisted can disney get
and that that definitely answered the
question
and they can go straight to the pits
so basically it's kind of like i've
heard this with other people's
testimonies too like they don't believe
in god until
suddenly their eyes are open to just how
evil the world is and they're like oh
if the world is like this evil there's
got to be something else
if you've ever seen the testimony of the
hollywood stunt man he did the
documentary called outer shadows that's
what happened to him did you guys see
that mm-hmm
you told me about it i just haven't had
the chance so try and find it it's like
you probably only find it on bit shoot
now but
um that thing got millions of views like
every day i was getting a million views
because he was a hollywood stunt man
like the most
prominent one of our time and he got in
a really bad accident and was kind of
like bedridden for a while
and when he's going to this nurse she
was like can i pray for you and he's
like i guess or whatever
and she was saying you know i see i see
a lot of stuff in this hospital you know
we're in hollywood i'm i see a lot of
crazy stuff come in here and she's
talking about satanic ritual abuse and
things like this
and he was like what is she talking
about and so he started looking it up
and it was like his eyes were open to a
lot of things that he had been
involved in that he didn't realize like
things he had seen happening behind the
scenes
and he just was blind to it but now he
was like wow and he made a whole
documentary exposing
just how evil that industry is wow and
so when you see
owl house why is there such a
a drive to push witchcraft why is it
such a drive to make a cartoon about a
girl who hangs out with a witch in hell
you know it's like it's got to be
satanically inspired it just doesn't
make sense why you would push this so
much so
yeah you reach that place you're kind of
like this is evil
yeah i mean as an atheist and you're
wondering why are they why are they
pushing this fairy tale so much you know
yeah because it's a religion too
it is it definitely is it was uh it was
a complete shock to me for sure
you know it uh it kind of got me closer
to god if anything so i guess i got to
thank them for that
that's awesome so yeah wouldn't that be
an ironic spin like the owl house made
me a christian
[Music]
but little light saved our marriage
i mean is that like true like how this
how does this work because what do you
think would happen if
you didn't stumble upon the videos or
sent them to him do you think the same
outcome would happen i mean it could
have possibly but
i think it's interesting you know i
think that there's a lot of things that
you guys covered
that i didn't understand was happening
in my life for instance you guys had i
think her name was leah on here and she
was talking about her
um her coming from what was a new age
stuff
to a christian and when i started
watching her she was talking about like
reiki
and stuff like that and i did reiki
before and so i was like
oh like and then i started releasing all
these demonic like holes that were on my
life
and as a christian i was being like
oppressed by like demons and i was into
like rock and roll and
you know i shared my test you shared my
testimony where i'm talking about how
i was literally singing songs and like
going to concerts with my devil horns up
talking about how
devil's god and god's a liar like those
are the song those are the lyrics that i
was
listening to and i did reiki and ever
since then like
i felt different after doing that and
it's it's very demonic and it's not
godly at all and so certain things like
that that you guys put out that helped
me change myself
and realize like oh wow this is what
that
is that's why i feel like this after
that happened to me
and so especially when she was talking
about like raking different things that
she was
you know encountering which i did too so
i was like whoa
i was doing that as someone who believed
in god and now i see that that's
where so it's like you guys helped guide
me into changing my character
by reading the bible and like you know
um looking more into what you guys are
saying and
you know finding the scripture and you
guys always add like scripture into your
show so i'm like oh that seems
interesting and then i'll pull up my
bible and start reading more so
it turned into that and then we just
started it just started something that
we
um started doing together watching all
your videos and he was obsessed with
video games so i showed him
the first thing i did i was like okay
you like these videos watch this video
game
yeah so i made him watch the video game
one and literally he got rid of his xbox
like he was
like no like we're not playing video
games anymore i'm not doing that
and so it was like little things like
that that helped really realize
the different things in our lives that
we needed to change
so or fix you know there are certain
things that i didn't understand about
myself
that i had to change and then watching
your guys's videos and you guys covering
these different subjects really
helped us praise the lord that's really
like our mission like
i always say that there's too many
parents that just say you can't do that
it's bad you know yeah
why not because i said so they don't
really have the answer and and i feel
sorry for the parents because they are
trying to protect their child but they
don't have the knowledge
so that really just makes the child well
be rebellious and i'll do it behind your
back
so we want to put out information like
of all types of topics like
homosexuality new age movement and it's
interesting that you said that
her testimony showed you some things
that you dealt with
and uh and i'm just i praise god that
you guys are where you're at today
because
i've seen like you said like you saw the
video games bam i'm gonna make the
decision
and you guys are at the point where i'm
a believer jesus is
lord of my life so many people say he's
my lord my king but
they don't really obey him they don't
really there's no life change but
if he is your lord that means he's your
master
and so we should get to the point where
we're like even if
god i don't understand it but you say it
i'm going to do it i trust that you
have my best interest in your heart and
so
that's where you're at yeah like maybe
like well it's just a video game but
then you start seeing things well i'm
going to get rid of it i've seen you
guys do this
a lot and at first i was kind of like oh
i hope this isn't like
you know a drastic thing yeah
a real quick thing because some people
can be like uh
just make these knee jerk reactions and
we're going to do all this stuff and
then it
well they get over real fast yeah
or it's like yeah they get so much
persecution from the world that's like
well maybe we're just making a big deal
out of it but you guys i mean we've been
talking for like six seven months and
it's just been progressive and i love
seeing the growth
yeah it's so awesome man we get i get
comments um
from the little like facebook and some
people are actually
hesitant to share our videos because
they're like well we don't want to be
pushy
and we don't know how it'll be received
so i'd love to hear your perspective
daniel how
how did you feel receiving these videos
from michaela
you know like did you think she was
being pushy or um
also when it came to make a decision
tell me what was going on in your mind
so when she was sending me the videos i
i really didn't think too much of it
i i wasn't like you know angered by it
or anything i wasn't
disgruntled by it in any kind of way i
just oh
sent me a video okay i'll watch it sure
why not cool what hard can i do
you know i mean that's uh i i have the
same mindset though when i first started
out being a christian
i i was afraid that oh am i gonna push
people away am i going to
make him angry at me and you did i was a
little aggressive though i
definitely was a little aggressive
militant atheist turned militant
christian
oh yeah i went a 180 degree turn just
whoo
started playing for this i would have
the tell like okay let's comment down a
little bit
because like he was like in this group
chat with all his friends and he would
just send him all these videos and i'm
like
they don't think like that though and
now i'm like
i'm like do it yeah yeah like if you're
gonna send one video at a time
do it if you're gonna just bombard him
the way i did i wouldn't recommend it
um and then what was the other question
i'm sorry when it came to making a
decision
whether you're going to keep playing
video games or whatever the case what
was going through your mind
um honestly at that point i was
started walking a lot stronger with god
as soon as i saw you guys video
i was like you know i'm unplugging this
i'm
turning it all off i'm not gonna
hesitate doing this that's what god
wants me to do i'ma do it
so basically what you're saying is like
you had something better to fill that
time with no
i mean that's the thing so many people
try to like my cold turkey just quit
this thing and then they're just sitting
there bored twisting their thumbs
well you got to fill that void again so
yeah yeah
yeah you get i don't you know i don't
handle the devil's playground that's
like such a true statement
and for me like when i gave up alcohol i
had to replace it with
drinking a gallon of water until i
couldn't think about putting a beer in
my body
and so for you i don't know what you did
but you were
at a part where at a point where you
were doing better things with your time
whereas before you were just an atheist
playing video games
ignoring your girlfriend yeah well do
you remember the day that we totally got
because we still used his xbox as like a
dvd player
and so i actually think you know marco
polo what happened is we were having
a lot of spiritual warfare like a lot of
friends family is like
arguing with us and all the stuff so
anyways i'm like in my room and we're
praying and
i was like i just started thinking about
you know that one thing that i think
scotty said
about how there was like some guy who
said that the records that you have or
the amount of demons that you
own or whatever and so i literally was
like oh we got to get rid of my records
because i had like a record player and
all my you know
metal music and i was like okay we gotta
get rid of these and then
we got rid of them and then i was like i
still feel something wrong what do we do
and then he's like the x-box
so we got rid of the xbox and then yeah
now we don't have it so
you know i i totally think that was true
you know
true experience i saw it you were like
look at this there's a serpent on it you
know all the records had to say
yeah there was like a serpent and just
to say like
you know i don't i don't know if the the
plastic forming the xbox is actually
satanic but i think god knew that that
was a temptation in your life oh yeah
you're using it for netflix but then
you're going to be bored with that let's
oh
it's a new game right there absolutely
and god wanted to get
that temptation out because if you're if
you're a
a meth head you don't uh put the pipe on
yourself and be like oh
it just looks pretty you know yeah i
just got a collection of pipes it's okay
i still collect meth pipes you know i
don't smoke anymore but
yeah i know that method is looking good
that's awesome yeah the bible says
um have courage be courageous when
you're sharing your faith so that's
really awesome
when you think of like if you if there's
a good sale at a store or you just have
this
good information that you know will help
your friend you go and tell them you're
not hesitant like whoa you like this i
like this i found this deal
here's the information we should be just
as on fire for the lord
exactly scattering those seeds it's not
our responsibility to
uh make the seed grow we just scatter
the seeds it's god that's you know
softening the hearts of everybody
and that's our job we're throwing out we
never know you know
how long it'll take you could you could
share a video like that with somebody
and they might not watch it
and then uh years down the line yeah
years down the road
that it pops up in their algorithm wait
a minute i saw that video somebody
shared with me
and that's the timing it's all god's
timing you know i think that's the way
it was with
how you stumbled stumbled upon little
light and shared with him you know you
guys are at a a point where you're ready
for it
not everybody's ready for it but yeah
don't take it don't take it personally
yeah you know i forget who it was um
when they were telling oh i think it was
elijah
and god counseled him they're not
rejecting you oh yes it was when the
israelites were asking for their first
king
and god is saying they're not rejecting
you they're rejecting me so don't take
it so personally when people
push back on what you have to share yeah
that's so true yeah
christ is not rejecting you know like
talking about like progress time i still
remember when i watched you know little
light video
i watched when i was in middle school
but then
i actually stopped going to the cinema
when i was in high school so like
it took time yeah but it was something
it's lasting the result yeah yeah it was
definitely something super fast for us
too it's like it started off with us
getting rid of the xbox our records
and now we just don't watch any like
secular anything because we just know
exactly what the motives are and
you know we just try to go to church
watch sermons like that's
practically what we utilize youtube for
is like obviously watching you guys
because we're like huge fans
and um definitely like different sermons
and going to church reading our bibles
we study every single day and then he
reads a chapter to me every night
yeah so we just try as much as we can to
just
fill our time that we have with either
spending it with family and doing things
that are like productive
or just totally you know reading the
bible and searching and getting closer
to god
yeah god's word is is transforming and
praying yeah
always pray always pray if you don't get
in his word you're not going to have any
transformation and as a christian
we're supposed to get in his word his
word is how he communicates to us and
i mean when you get in there he will
transform you and
renew your mind and that's where we
should be the word is our sword and like
there's so many times that i've gone
through something where someone says
something to me and i just like had a
verse like straight just like go right
through like my head and i'm like that's
exactly what
when you fill your life with that it
makes you stronger with your
relationship with him and others and
or sometimes it would just go through
something and then as you're reading the
bible
you see boom perfect verse oh i
understand this now
or oh that makes complete sense why this
happened
or this verse really helps me get
through with what just happened
yeah god can use our hardships to refine
us
and teach us a lesson and and also to
help us
to identify with people who are in that
situation you know there's
i remember hearing a pastor say that uh
there was somebody
in a hospital bed and and one nurse
would come in and just throw them all
around and
it's like oh you know she's just doing
her job or whatever but there's another
nurse that was like
real gentle with him and he was like oh
wow thank you so much she
you the other lady felt like i was you
know she was a professional wrestler in
here and she goes well you know what
i've been exactly where you're at and
that's why i'm you know cautious with
you and stuff
so i think god allows us he doesn't put
us in those situations but he allows us
to go through certain situations
so that we can identify with people and
help them you know
so you guys were saying how now you you
love watching sermons
online and reading your bible and things
like that um some people may hear that
and say wow that's like so boring
compared to what i'm doing right now
for being honest i mean there's a lot of
sucky shows today right and
you look at what's in the bible we're
talking about stories of like assassins
and miracles and all these things
happening so i'm curious
how long did it take for you guys for
your taste buds to change for your
spiritual taste buds so to speak
because to quit uh video games cold
turkey and then
open up a bible i mean no it's not
flickering on the page you know it may
not
it may not be easy to hold your
attention so maybe if you could share
some tips or how long the transition was
for someone who may be considering going
down that same road
well if anything i kind of started off
as a lukewarm christian i was a little
bit
doing both so i was playing video games
and then i was listening to maybe a
couple sermons watching a couple led
videos
and it kind of just as soon as i watched
your guys's video that's when i was like
all right
i'm going full into just the sermons i'm
going full
into just the apologetic stuff i'm going
straight to pure flicks and just
watching
nothing but christian shows um
and there's some stuff on pure flicks
that we don't even
we were like oh this is this is not yeah
it's too secular yeah this is
biblical so you definitely gotta pick
and choose what you watch there
but um yeah no it was a
i it was an immediate transition to let
go of the xbox
for sure but it was a slow transition
into more of the
christian lifestyle i'm supposed to be
living okay and for me i just felt like
very hungry for the word and it's like
all i wanted to know and so it's like
and seeing all the symbolism and all the
things that you guys talk about in your
shows helps me like recognize that when
i'm watching something secular and it
just like
made it like my loss of appetite for
that it's like i didn't want nothing to
do with that because
it was definitely like hindering my
relationship with god
and i felt that and so it's like what's
more important watching this show
that has horrible you know morals and
all the stuff or
just being hungry for god and then you
and then you could actually use your
imagination
yeah and like how you picture things in
the bible and
stuff like that so i just felt like very
hungry and it's like that's all i wanted
and obviously i would pray i always
prayed before like to give me patience
and
to you know light up the words off the
page and to make me
just hungry for that every single time
before i read the bible i always pray
that's so important like i think we just
we
do not take prayer really seriously you
know it's become one of those things
like good luck like i'll pray for you
but yeah
they never really do the action of doing
it i make it a point like if anyone ever
and i do i get a lot of messages from
people like pray for me and i
i think that's such an awesome thing
that that person knows where the power
is that person says
i'm dealing with this i'm going to ask
for somebody to pray for me like that's
that just shows me that you know that
they really want to be free
or whatever and so if they're taking the
if they're humiliating or humbling
themselves to the point of
i'm going to ask this person to pray for
me about this personal thing i'm i'm
going to take that seriously i'm going
to do it i mean i'm going to literally
take time out of my day and pray to god
and there is power and prayer we just
we uh we take it for granted we don't
yeah i believe the angels are just
looking at us like
just pray what are you doing yeah i have
the powers unlimited resources
but also conviction like there's times
like i'm scrolling through youtube times
from
instead of actually reading my bible and
i feel like no girl you gotta pray
like you gotta read your bible you gotta
do your own research got to do that and
it's like conviction it's like the holy
spirit's like girl
you've been on youtube for too long come
on read it yourself and i deal with that
i drive an hour to work
first thing i want to do is like put
some video on there and then i'm like no
i have to make myself like i'm i've put
the phone over here i'm going to spend
this hour
drive in prayer you just have to make
yourself do it but it's like
exercise you know it's not fun at first
but then after a while you start
realizing like oh i didn't exercise
today i need to do that you know
it becomes something that you you crave
and you know you need to do
yeah i love how practical you guys got
and it's like two different perspectives
from the both of you
um i remember when i decided to stop
eating cheese right and my friend
decided that as well
i was able to quit cold turkey i haven't
had cheese in like three four years now
but she was like okay i'm just gonna
like not eat cheese on sundays
take it a week at a time but i think the
most important thing is
is progress listening to the holy spirit
promptings praying
and just progress don't be too hard on
yourself each person is different and
their walk is different
so thank you so much for sharing that so
i think your story is beautiful
and i hope it blessed somebody else out
there if you guys
have been influenced by little light
studios we'd love to hear your testimony
as well put that down in the comments
section
and i'm sure dana mckayla will be
reading it too and you can interact with
them
thank you guys for joining us this week
and don't forget to
like subscribe and share with your
friends scatter those
seeds you never know what might happen
and whose life you might change
god bless you guys see you next friday
hey youtube do we need god's law
[Music]
do we need god's law let's explore that
question together
in five minutes or less
[Music]
so
you